el globo chino que Estados Unidos acusa
de haber sido enviado a espiar en su
espacio aéreo no habría sido el único la
Casa Blanca reveló informes de que al
menos tres de estos artefactos
sobrevolaron el país durante la
administración del republicano Donald
Trump Y al menos otro lo hizo en la del
actual presidente Joe biden
descubrimos estos vuelos después de que
asumimos el cargo y no voy a entrar en
detalles sobre cómo hicimos los análisis
forenses creo que pueden entender que
vamos a tener cuidado pero nos dimos
cuenta de que en al menos tres ocasiones
los globos de vigilancia de la República
popular china transitaron por el espacio
aéreo de los Estados Unidos y es que
este tema ha tensado las relaciones
entre Washington y Beijing en un momento
en el que la Casa Blanca buscaba
relajarlas con el viaje a la capital
china que el secretario de estado
Anthony blinquen tenía previsto para la
semana pasada pero que fue suspendido
ahora la administración biden asegura
que el descubrimiento no cambiará la
intención del presidente de distensionar
El Trato con el asiático
depende de China averiguar Qué tipo de
relación quieren y como saben Sí el
secretario blingen pues puso su viaje No
Fue cancelado nuevamente no cambia lo
que estamos tratando de hacer y cómo
estamos tratando de movernos con china
Estados Unidos sigue manteniendo que el
globo buscaba espiar sitios sensibles
para la seguridad nacional china por su
parte mantiene que este era de uso civil
y que tenía como propósito Investigar la
meteorología por lo que criticó que
Estados Unidos optará por derribarlo